نحن نبني هذا الجدار ، فأنت بحاجة إلى 500
ميل ،
لكن 700 سيكون جيدًا ، سيكون 750 أو نحو ذلك
رائعًا
لن يكون هناك قدم أخرى من الجدار
مبنية
في إدارتي إذا جاء الناس إلى
بلدنا بشكل غير قانوني ،
فهم يخرجون ولن يأتوا
بشكل غير قانوني ويقيمون ونريد
أن يأتي الناس ولكننا نريدهم أن يأتوا من
خلال الجدارة
الصحيحة ونريد أن يحب الأشخاص الذين
سيأتون بلدنا
لا يكرهون
الوافدين الجدد لبلدنا يجب أن يكونوا
مكتفين ذاتيًا من الناحية المالية
لا يمكنهم قبول الرعاية الاجتماعية لمدة خمس سنوات على الأقل ،
لدينا حظر سفر كبير الآن بالنسبة
للبلدان التي ليست دولًا
لا نريد أن يأتي الأشخاص إليها ،
لقد قمنا بإصلاح سياسة اللاجئين بالكامل ،
وقمنا بوضع فحوصات أمنية وطنية صارمة.
الأقليات الدينية المحمية
وقمنا بتحويل قبول اللاجئين بعيدًا
عن
الدول المنكوبة بالإرهاب مثل سوريا
والصومال.
عند التأكد من أننا نستخدم
قدرة عالية
التقنية للتعامل معها ، فإن أول
شيء سأفعله وقد كتبت بالفعل
إرسال مسار aaaa إلى كونغرس الولايات المتحدة
للحصول على الجنسية لـ 11
مليون شخص غير مسجلين ،
سنقوم باستعادة  المكانة الأخلاقية في
العالم ودورنا التاريخي كملاذ آمن
للاجئين وطالبي اللجوء
والذين يفرون من العنف والاضطهاد
سنوقف الممارسة اللاإنسانية
المتمثلة في فصل الأطفال عن
والديهم
والعمل على لم شمل العائلات ، انظر إلى
جميع العائلات  التي لم يتم لم شملها ،
سنتوقف عن احتجاز الأشخاص
ونستثمر بالتأكيد بدلاً من ذلك في
برامج إدارة الحالات
للمساعدة في ضمان حصول المهاجرين على الدعم
الذي يحتاجون إليه أثناء التنقل في
عملية اللجوء.
طاولة العمل
مع حلفائنا وشركائنا
طالما أنني رئيس ، سنضع أمريكا دائمًا في
المرتبة الأولى لسنوات وسنوات
نضع البلدان الأخرى في المقام الأول ،
ونحن الآن  ضع أمريكا أولاً في العمل بشكل
تعاوني مع الدول
الأخرى لمشاركة قيمنا وأهدافنا لا
تجعل أمريكا كما يبدو مطبقًا في
هذه الإدارة ،
فهي تجعلنا أكثر أمانًا يمكننا من أن نكون
أكثر نجاحًا ،
ولا يوجد بلد حتى في قوة بلدنا
يمكن أن يذهب بمفرده  في تحديات
القرن الحادي والعشرين ،
تثري العولمة الدول الأجنبية على
حسابنا
العولمة أنا أحب بلدنا
أنا رئيس الولايات المتحدة
الأمريكية لست رئيس أمريكا العالمية
أولاً لا يعني
أمريكا وحدها عندما تكون الولايات المتحدة
ينمو
كذلك هل خلق الرخاء الأمريكي العالمي
وظائف لا حصر لها في
جميع أنحاء العالم
لن يتوقف حتى نتغلب على nra
ولن يتوقف الأمر حتى نحظر
الأسلحة الهجومية القاتلة حتى نحمل
مصنعي الأسلحة مسؤولية هناك مشكلة
مرض
عقلي يجب أن  أن يتم التعامل
معها ، فليس المسدس هو الذي يضغط على الزناد ،
إنه الشخص الذي يحمل البندقية ،
أي واحد منكم ،
ويجب أن يتمكن الأشخاص الذين ورائي من الدخول إلى المحكمة  للمطالبة
بأن يتحمل مصنعو الأسلحة بأرباحهم
الهائلة أرباحهم الهائلة
المسؤولية عن المذبحة التي
تسببوا بها
في مجتمعنا في أول يوم لي في منصبي ،
سأرسل مشروع القانون إلى
الكونغرس
لإلغاء حماية المسؤولية
عن  يقوم مصنعو الأسلحة
بإغلاق ثغرات التحقق في الخلفية
وفترة الانتظار ،
حيث سيسمح ذلك للكثير من الأشخاص الذين يسمحون الآن
للعديد من الأشخاص بالمرور عبر الشقوق ،
فنحن نبحث في عمليات التحقق من الخلفية
وننظر في تجميع كل شيء
معًا بطريقة موحدة بحيث
يمكننا الحصول على شيء ذي مغزى
في نفس الوقت الذي
نرغب فيه جميعًا في حماية تعديلنا الثاني العظيم ،
يجب أن نتأكد من أن أولئك الذين
يُحكم عليهم بأنهم يشكلون خطرًا جسيمًا على السلامة العامة
لا يمكنهم الوصول إلى الأسلحة النارية
وأنهم إذا فعلوا تلك الأسلحة النارية  تم أخذها من
خلال الإجراءات القانونية الواجبة السريعة وهذا هو السبب في
أنني دعوت إلى قوانين العلم الأحمر
المعروفة أيضًا باسم أوامر الحماية من المخاطر الشديدة ،
يريد الديمقراطيون مرشحًا يقوم بالبناء
على obamacare لا تتخلص منه
ثم انضم إلينا ،
نحن الآن نقترب خطوة واحدة من تحرير
مواطنينا
من كابوس obamacare هذا الآن
نحتاج إلى إنهاء المهمة
للتأكد من أن كل أمريكي
لديه خيار في الرعاية الصحية بأسعار معقولة
مغطاة بخيار عام أ
خيار شبيه بالرعاية الطبية إذا كنت تتفاوض بشأن
اتفاقية رعاية صحية
مع نقابة صاحب العمل أو غير ذلك
وترغب في ذلك
لأنك تخليت عن الأجور للحصول عليها ،
يمكنك الاحتفاظ بها يجب أن تكون اختيارك
ولكن إذا لم تفعل ذلك  لا
تعجبك إذا لم تعجبك ، يمكنك تركها عن طريق
زيادة الإعانات المقدمة لأفراد الطبقة
الوسطى لشراءها مما سيقلل بشكل كبير
من تكلفة الأدوية الموصوفة
ولأول مرة سيجبر
شركات التأمين على التنافس
على عملك ليس فقط مع  بعضنا
البعض ولكن مع منافس عام
ونحن ندافع عن حقك
في الاحتفاظ بالطبيب والحفاظ على
خطتك المختارة ،
لقد قتلنا التفويض الفردي الذي
هو الأكثر
فظاعة
والذي لا يمكن تصديقه.  lly obamacare بعد الآن
ولكننا ندير
الهيكل ونحاول القضاء
عليه تمامًا وبعد ذلك سنعيده ،
وستحصل على رعاية صحية رائعة
كنت في المكتب لمدة ثلاث
سنوات ونصف السنة لم تفعلها  لدينا أشخاص لم نحصل
عليهم
أه عذرًا سمعتموني بالأمس
نحن نوقع خطة رعاية صحية في
غضون أسبوعين خطة رعاية صحية كاملة وكاملة
أن قرار المحكمة العليا بشأن داكا
منحني الحق في القيام
بذلك نحن  سنحل ، سنوقع على
خطة الهجرة
وخطة رعاية صحية وخطط أخرى مختلفة
يجب على كل حاكم أن
يفرض ارتداء قناع إلزامي لا يتعلق الأمر بحقوقك ،
بل يتعلق بمسؤولياتك
كأمريكي ، سنواصل حث
الأمريكيين على ارتداء
الأقنعة عندما لا يتمكنون من الناحية الاجتماعية  بعد المسافة
ولكننا لسنا بحاجة إلى إلقاء العبء
الكامل على الحكومة الفيدرالية
على الأمريكيين الملتزمين بالقانون لتحقيق
هذا الهدف إذا كان رئيسنا اليوم سوف
يتراجع
عن إعادة الافتتاح في عدد من الأماكن
لأن
الماسكارا تبدو نظيفة.  يُحدث التباعد الجماعي والتباعد الاجتماعي
فرقًا كبيرًا من
حيث انتشار هذا المرض ،
ويريد الجميع أن تكون مدارسنا
مفتوحة ، والسؤال هو كيف نجعلها آمنة
كيف نجعلها تلتصق بإجبار طلاب التعليم على
العودة إلى الفصل الدراسي
في المناطق التي يكون فيها معدل الإصابة
يرتفع أو يظل مرتفعًا للغاية
هو مجرد اختبار خطير عادي ،
اختبار المزيد من الاختبارات ليس
فقط كيفية العثور على المزيد من حالات
فيروس كورونا
السيد الرئيس ، إنه كيفية إيقاف اختبار
حالات فيروس كورونا
متبوعًا بتتبع صارم للاتصال ،
نعم أعتقد أن المدارس يجب أن
تفتح
أبوابنا نريد  من أجل إنعاش اقتصادنا ، أعتقد
أنه من المهم للغاية بالنسبة
للاقتصاد تشغيل المدارس ،
لا نريد إغلاق المدارس ،
نريد أن
تفتح المدارس ، وخاصة الأطفال الصغار جدًا الذين
يتعاملون مع
الأطفال جميعهم ، وخاصة
الأطفال الصغار جدًا  تعامل مع الأمر بشكل جيد للغاية ،
لذلك نريد أن تفتح المدارس عمليات الإغلاق هذه
تعتبر
عقابية للغاية ، فهي
تؤذي الكثير من الأشخاص في كثير من الأحيان  من
خلال الاكتئاب من خلال
الانتحار من خلال العديد من الأشياء الأخرى ،
تعاطي المخدرات الكحولية في كل مرة تختبر فيها
تجد حالة وتعرف أنه يتم
الإبلاغ عنها في الأخبار وجدنا المزيد من الحالات
إذا بدلاً من 50 فعلنا 25
سنحصل على نصف عدد الحالات لذلك أنا
أنا شخصياً أعتقد أنه مبالغ فيه ولكني
على استعداد تام لمواصلة القيام بذلك